[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce que l'anthropologie
l'anthropologie c'est l'étude de l'homme
et des sociétés
l'anthropologie va s'atteler à mettre en
tension la diversité des cultures au
prisme de l'unité de l'homme
classiquement lorsqu'on le va me
demander d'étudier ou d'analyser un
phénomène social je vais mettre en
tension l'écart entre ce que les gens
disent est ce que les gens font entre ce
que les gens font
est-ce que les gens voudraient avoir en
somme l'anthropologie cd construire pour
mieux reconstruire la réalité en faisant
ce qu'on appelle un détour
anthropologique donc un détour
anthropologique c'est quoi c'est prendre
de la hauteur pour penser de manière
différente
un phénomène social le célèbre
anthropologue claude lévi strauss il
avait très bien montré au sujet de la
prohibition de l'inceste
l'anthropologue s'étonnait que quelles
que soient les cultures il y avait
toujours le même interdit l'interdît
d'épouser femme tente et soeurs de notre
groupe social mais avec ce détour
anthropologique en opérant ce qu'on
appelle un renversement conceptuel on se
rend compte que ce n'est pas une
interdiction mais une obligation
d'épouser femme tente et soeurs d'autres
cultures pour la perduration de l'
équilibre économique ou politique
ce soir je ne vais pas vous livrer un
témoignage je ne vais pas parler de moi
mais je vais faire ce que
l'anthropologie sait très bien faire
c'est à dire opérer un détour vous
pointez du doigt un certain nombre
d'éléments pour vous amener à réfléchir
à réfléchir sur cette question de
l'égalité et du genre dans notre société
pour commencer on peut se poser une
question une question qui n'amène pas
forcément une réponse immédiate mais qui
ouvre le champ de la réflexion
actuellement les questions d'égalité se
limitait la notion d'homme et de femme
où sommes nous face à l'émergence d'un
troisième genre et si troisième genre il
y a de quelle nature et il est sain
troisième genre produit par nous mêmes
par notre société
ou alors est-ce une nouvelle manière de
vivre notre masculinité et notre
féminité au quotidien pour essayer
d'apporter des clés de lecture et des
clés de compréhension à cette question
là je vais avoir une démonstration en
trois parties d'abord on s'intéressera à
l' influence à l'incidence des croyances
dans la perduration des relations de
genre dans nos sociétés après on
s'intéressera davantage aux objets des
objets qui comme vous
le voir sont des marqueurs sociétaux et
qui permettent de mieux comprendre ces
fameuses inégalités du genre et enfin on
s'intéressera à l'innovation qui rend
possible une certaine évolution de la
question du genre pour essayer de
pointer du doigt un petit peu les
limites
pour commencer je vous parlais d'une
expérience une expérience
anthropologique que j'ai menée avec 25
de mes collaborateurs cet été 25 hommes
et femmes issus des métiers du design du
commerce de la communication de la
recherche de l'industrie parce que ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est que tu
l'entrepôt locke du groupe seb donc au
sein de chez seb
mon rôle est de faire le lien entre ce
qui se passe dans la vraie vie dans la
société
est ce que le marketing design et la
recherche vont imaginer en termes de
produits de demain
donc l'objectif de cette expérience c
est pouvoir concevoir de manière
différence des mythologies des histoires
qui accompagneront le futur de nos
objets parce que ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que sem a créé avec moulinex
libère la femme
un mythe moderne de la femme il a
accompagné l'émancipation de cette femme
hors de la sphère domestique tout en
assurant une perduration de l' équilibre
familial
donc comme on le voit avec cette
nouvelle mythologie c'est permettait
d'expliquer ce qui se passait à son
époque par exemple comme vous le voyez
avec cette publicité des années 60 la
publicité et à destination des hommes
parce que ce qu'il faut se rappeler
c'est qu'à cette époque les femmes
n'avaient pas le chéquier et c'était
l'homme qui qui signe l échec donc
effectivement elle avait le droit de
sortir de la maison
mais pour ça fallait qu'elle reste une
bonne mère et une bonne épouse
donc comme vous le voyez c'est vraiment
des objets qui accompagnent des
générations de femmes et qui permettent
d'expliquer la société dans laquelle
elles sont donc à la suite de cette
expérience que j'ai menée avec mes
collaborateurs ce qui est très
intéressant c'est qu'ils ont réussi à
s'émanciper des contraintes techniques
actuelles pour créer vraiment une
innovation dit pervasif mais par contre
ils n'ont pas du tout réussi à
s'émanciper des questions du genre
pire la technologie apparaissait comme
un moyen de faire perdurer ces
inégalités
par exemple on avait une mythologie
autour d'une fleuriste qui faisaient que
légitimer l'harcèlement et la drague de
rue on avait une autre exemple
auprès d' une chef cuisinière étoilé qui
était certes meilleures que les hommes
mais pour pouvoir conserver sa place
elle devait négocier et renoncer à ce
fameux restaurant qu'est-ce que cet
exemple nous apprend il nous apprend que
les structures anthropologiques sont
coriaces et qu'il est très très
compliqué de faire évoluer cette
question du genre
effectivement il n'y a pas de réponse
préconçues et simple à ce problème mais
par contre on se rend compte que la sur
représentation du masculin dans toutes
les cultures dans les métiers de la
technologie et d'innovation notamment
pour concevoir des produits sont des
produits tangibles ou des produits
digitaux peuvent être une clé
d'explication à ces problèmes de genre
autour des objets donc pour vous
illustrer ça je vais prendre deux
exemples celui des baruya et celui du
sèche-cheveux
donc avant de commencer ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que dans toutes les
cultures les hommes ont peur des femmes
la mythologie leur prête des pouvoirs
extraordinaires et pour les rendre
inoffensive
il faut les contrôler et ça le les
baruya qui a un pub de nouvelle guinée
ils ont mis en place d' habile stratégie
de maintien et de contrôle par exemple
pour la chasse donc certes les femmes
ont droit de chasser et par contre avec
des objets qui sont fabriqués par les
hommes
et comme ils ne sont pas fous sont mis à
disposition des hommes des objets très
performant qui leur permettent d'
excellent chasseur et al'inverse sont
mis à disposition des femmes des objets
rudimentaires qui ne leur permettent pas
de chasser et comme elles reviennent
bredouilles de la chasse elles sont
assignés à la préparation des festins
d'après chasse pour plus d' équilibre
dans le partage des tâches domestiques
autre exemple la limitation des
interactions du genre dans l'espace
public
là encore les baruya ont la réponse ils
ont créé de chemin un chemin pour les
hommes et un chemin pour les femmes mais
comme c'est une idée qui vient du
masculin le chemin pour les hommes
surplombe toujours celui des femmes
histoire de conserver le contrôle
maintenant je vais vous parler d'un
autre exemple d'un autre exemple qui
vous allez le voir va changer votre
manière au quotidien d'être dans votre
salle de bain c'est la fabuleuse
histoire du sèche-cheveux donc le
sèche-cheveux a été inventé en 1926 où
le dirais qu'il a sans doute
révolutionner le quotidien de millions
ou 2 milliards de femmes mais par contre
ce que l'on sait moins c'est que le
sèche-cheveux est une invention
un homme pour les femmes mais avec son
propre système de référence donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
ils ont simplement transférer la
technologie d'une perceuse pour le
séchage les cheveux donc effectivement
c'est normal mesdames si vous trouvez
votre appareil lourd et peu pratique
il a sans doute été inventé par un homme
qui n'avait aucune idée de la difficulté
du brushing sur cheveux longs le matin
donc je vous la corne 7,7 exemple porte
à sourire et est assez positif même si
ça a conduit encore à nouvelles
inégalités du genre ça part d'une bonne
intention
la robotique aussi semble pavé de bonnes
intentions
par exemple on a les robots qui vise à
limiter la solitude avec les robots de
type assistant au conversationnel
on a encore un autre type de robot qui
vise à limiter l'insécurité dans les
espaces publics avec des robots de
sécurité mais si on s'intéresse un petit
peu plus au robot sexuel
on se rend compte que la réalité est
tout autre effectivement l'avancé
l'innovation et la technologie nous
amène à avoir une ressemblance de plus
en plus forte avec ce type d'appareil
texture de la peau micro expressions
tout est fait pour nous renvoyer vers
notre propre humanité
mais depuis quelques mois et
commercialiser une poupée programmé pour
être violée je vous la corne
cela peut paraître fou mais
malheureusement ce n'est pas une fausse
information
son inventeur se défend dé des critiques
des critiques en expliquant que cette
innovation à un bien fait sociétal il
permettrait par exemple de limiter les
agressions sexuelles dans les lieux
publics
or d'un point de vue anthropologique on
se risque davantage à une normalisation
du viol à le concevoir comme un simple
programme de la sexualité et la question
qui se pose à présent c'est de se dire
avons nous le droit de tout créer pour
assouvir les besoins de l'humanité
l'avènement d'une société de viol ne
signifie pas le début d'une société sans
limite et sans limite
avons nous un devenir si je vous pose
cette question là c'est que quand je
vous parlais l'émergence d'un troisième
genre on peut se demander si elle si les
relations du genre c'est limite à celle
de l'homme et de la femme
et si on ne peut pas non plus on ne doit
pas y inclure
du robot actuellement ça peut paraître
encore fou est loin de notre quotidien
mais si on fait un pas en arrière de
seulement 100 ans tout semble possible
pour rappel en 1931 à paris s'exposait
des os humains ou la figure des peuples
traditionnels extra européens n'avaient
pas la même place et le même poids que
la figure du blanc européen en 2015
plus proche de nous un orang outan est
reconnu comme personne non humaine
hélas l'actualité nous rattrape il y a
quelques jours l'arabie saoudite vient
d'être le premier pays du monde a
déclaré un humanoïde comme citoyens
ayant exactement les mêmes droits que
les hommes et les femmes
je vous présente sofia et sofia pour
rappel ça veut quand même dire sagesse
donc face à tout ça on est quand même en
droit de se poser la question en se
disant comment dès à présent on doit
repenser les questions d'égalité du
genre et que au final cette
problématique qui nous amène ce soir ne
sera pas les problèmes d'égalité du
genre mais des gens qui nous amène à
repenser cette notion là en fait
actuellement nous sommes face à un
paradoxe si l'innovation et la
technologie apporte effectivement du
mieux être et du bien-être aux individus
de plus en plus intellectuel se pose la
question sur les incidences de ces
innovations et sur le devenir de notre
humanité
donc on va avoir des intellectuels comme
pic comme santolaria ou comme un mari
qui nous pose la question dès à présent
sur le digital sur les big data en se
demandant si les nouveaux combats que
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
pour lutter contre les grandes peurs de
l'humanité ne vont pas nous amener à
courir à notre perte
donc c'est quoi ces grands combats c'est
un combat contre le temps un combat
contre le vieillissement et celui de
déjouer la mort un combat sur la
génétique en essayant de s'améliorer soi
même grâce à la technologie et enfin une
évolution de nous mêmes on passerait
d'homo sapiens à homo des us en devenant
créateur de nous-mêmes et de créatures
qui nous ressemble avons nous toujours
cette humanité donc la poupe est
programmé pour être violée sofia en
arabie saoudite
je vous avoue que ce n'est pas forcément
hyper positif mais d'un autre côté on se
rend compte que d'autres innovations
technologiques sont davantage positives
et nous permettent de penser notre
masculinité notre féminité au quotidien
de manière différente par exemple
on a on a le cas de la procréation
assistée qu'on peut entrevoir comme
l'ultime émancipation de la femme face
aux devoirs de perduration l'espèce même
si la technique rend possible ça d'un
point de vue biologique le culturel
résiste le social s'emmène et provoque
des tensions psychologiques à titre
individuel autre exemple la féminisation
des traits morphologiques de sapiens
mais juste chez les hommes ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est que notre société conduit à
une baisse de la testostérone chez les
hommes
effectivement ils se battent - pour leur
survie ou pour celui de leur groupe
social et cette diminution de la
testostérone va entraîner une
féminisation de leurs traits
morphologiques
on pourrait également s'intéresser au
cas du design et des produits on revient
aux objets et on se rend compte que de
plus en plus de produits ou d'expérience
de rupture amène à un renouveau du
design beaucoup moins genre et que les
produits qu'on peut avoir actuellement
et enfin je vous parlais des créatifs
culturels
donc les créatifs culturels pour ceux
qui ne le savent pas c'est un groupe
social sans conscience de classe mais
qui va répondre à des aspirations des
sensibilités au monde similaire dans
différents domaines dont quels sont ils
l'écologie le développement durable la
cause animale les valeurs féministes la
psychose spiritualité et l'engagement
sociétal
donc c'est un groupe qui reste pour
l'instant silencieux mais qui a une
force de frappe très importante
il représente un tiers de la population
aux états unis un quart en europe et un
quart en asie est ce qui est intéressant
c'est que c'est un mouvement qui est sur
représentée par les femmes deux tiers de
son de ses membres sont des femmes
il se diffuse par le biais des espaces
publics non plus réelle mais virtuel si
vous deviez retenir quelque chose de
l'apport de l'anthropologie sur
l'émergence du troisième gens se
seraient sans doute de se dire que les
structures anthropologiques sont stables
et sont longues à bouger la période de
transition dans laquelle nous nous
situons actuellement nous conduit à voir
de manière un petit peu abrupte tout ce
qui va bien mais surtout tout ce qui va
pas bien et tout ce qui devrait changer
mais objectivement depuis moulinex
libère la femme
nous avons quand même eu des avancées
très intéressante
et puis n'oubliez pas vous êtes sans
doute un créatifs culturels sans le
savoir si vous intéresser à l'écologie
au développement durable et à toutes ces
nobles
cause vous oeuvrez chacun votre niveau à
un mouvement qui vous dépasse fait
d'hommes et de femmes qui ensemble
essaye de construire un monde meilleur
et comme j'ai commencé mon intervention
avec une définition de l'anthropologie
je terminerai avec un adage africain que
les anthropologues aime beaucoup
tant que les lions n'auront pas
d'historiens les récits de chasse
tourneront toujours à la gloire du
chasseur donc du coup j'en appelle à
votre conscience
j'en appelle à vos initiatives
individuelles pour que si dans cinq ans
ou dix ans on se réunit à nouveau ici
pour parler de ces problématiques
on soit tous un petit peu des historiens
du quotidien pour pouvoir déconstruire
la réalité opérer un détour
anthropologique et donner à voir une
réalité qui nous correspond davantage
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]